c'est avec un peu de cartons de coller
de peinture comme ochir 16 ans a donné
forme à sa ville idéale celle qu'il
espère pouvoir retrouver une fois que la
guerre au yémen sera terminée depuis la
prise de sanaa par les outils fin 2014
la capitale yéménite est fréquemment
frappée par les bombardements de la
coalition militaire conduite par
l'arabie saoudite
des raids aériens menés contre des
infrastructures civiles dont des
hôpitaux des pièces centrales de la
maquette de mots scheer ce qui me motive
pour faire ça ce sont les conséquences
de la guerre qui a frappé le pays en
termes de destruction des bâtiments
maintenant j'essaie de leur montrer
comment reconstruire les salles à ma
manière
une passion mais chez l'adolescent il ya
six ans au début de la guerre
aujourd'hui mme ochir espérons faire son
métier et aider à la reconstruction de
son pays
je lui demandé d'améliorer encore ses
compétences et d'affiner son talent afin
de faire avancer son ambition de faire
quelque chose de plus grand comme la
conception d'un grand bâtiment et
d'institutions pour qu'il passe à l'
architecture mais l'heure n'est pas
encore à la reconstruction
il ya quelques jours de nouveaux raids
aériens visant les outils ont été menées
sur la capitale sanaa
les premiers depuis des mois la guerre
au yémen a fait des dizaines de milliers
de morts selon plusieurs ong
internationales entraînant la pire crise
humanitaire actuelle selon l'onu